yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
and I am here from Great Britain
modulator yeah okay I'd probably not
such a great idea to play the drum it's
somewhat from the UK after all the
chopped off ski has shown very much
British opening with many players and
having big experience like Julian Hudson
or Spearman even Micky Arison played it
okay so we had the 94 line and yeah this
looks like a position on that could
maybe transpose into sort of a French
formation we have after this came let's
go to to a French
hmm okay then I'm threatening jeez ah no
just just winning the night and how this
was maybe the idea okay
okay let's play king f2 if he plays King
Queen to h4 I think I can just play g3
Knight takes HG Queen h1 and night h3
and the Queen songs are trapped yeah
this won't work
and now Queen c2 Bishop g2 wins the
Queen and I don't think I don't see a
defense
I'm also gaining a temper with Quincy -
on the bishop on c8 okay maybe he's
playing knight c6 so that's not tempo
but I really don't see what he can do
about Bishop g2 the b3 Knight is
covering the a1 look which is son
helping me
I'm actually surprised that he went for
Queen h4 rather quickly I think it's
pretty obvious that the queen is
strapped I don't know maybe you would
land resign yeah maybe you light on some
trick that that you know found it's not
working but yeah here I I really am I
really can do that the combat first is
skeptical but I don't think checking you
can save the piece yeah now it no yes is
that g3 is excellent yeah and this is
just just trapped yeah it gives white a
pretty big advantage yeah this is
important to do not see ghosts those
threats Queen h4 Queen age 5 those
checks check that look very frightening
at first still need to be calculated and
you quickly see that the Queen doesn't
have any squares it can only go to h2
and Queen c2 Bishop g2 is a fairly easy
way to trap it so a good thing to to to
note thanks for watching